it's a thought
today our car expert inna spaetzle is
putting some twin c4 cactus to the test
she notices right away that this model
is unusual instead of two individual
seats the cactuses - sofa style seats
form a seat bench divided in the center
by an armrest comfort and
user-friendliness were key to the
cactuses design since when also wanted
to keep the purchase price and operating
costs low so the designers and engineers
came up with some unique ideas and did
away with some old ones inna says
another special feature is the gear
selector lever on automatics
there isn't one this is the hand brake
drivers select the gears using these
three buttons the gauges are paired down
in modern the cactus has few buttons and
switches because all the operating
functions are controlled via the 7-inch
monitor which comes as standard
in his notes that the c4 cactus also
boasts another first the passenger
airbag is hidden in the roof in the case
of an accident it drops in front of the
windshield it's practical because it
frees up space for the glove compartment
once is that essential for a book the
trunk is also roomy though the rear seat
bench can only be folded down in one
piece it's a job best done by two people
though somewhat cumbersome this reduces
the cactus's weight by six kilos it's
pop-out rear windows save another 11
kilos he says it's not just the interior
airbags that are special
the exterior ones are to these airbump
panels contain tiny air capsules
designed to protect the doors from
getting scratched at the front the
headlights are also built into an air
bump this should help drivers save on
repair costs after minor fender benders
since when says the airbump panels don't
require any special maintenance
the panels come in four different colors
combined with a choice of ten different
colors of paint they allow buyers to
express their individual sense of style
under the hood our test car has a modern
three cylinder gasoline-powered engine
the twins concept of low maintenance
costs also includes low fuel consumption
the version we tested should travel 100
kilometers on 4.3 liters of gas the
start/stop system and the low body
weight helps in this the cactus weighs
around 200 kilograms less than the
standard model c4 in the basic version
our test car sells for just over 18
thousand euros in Germany of what inna
says that although it's it's when tried
to keep costs down you wouldn't know it
from the interior the materials feel
pleasant and looks well-made the
cactuses interior was styled to offer
ample space and comfort to passengers
and good visibility makes it a pleasure
to drive especially in the city
inna says the seats are comfy it's easy
to maneuver so that makes city driving a
joy but she's not fond of the way the
automatic transmission shifts quite late
and drags a little luckily there are a
few rocker switches that let you
intervene but it's not a very sporty car
our lowest aspartyl are constants and
with an output of 60 kilowatts and a
maximum torque of 118 Newton meters
the cactus isn't exactly a car for
adrenaline junkies it takes a full 15
seconds for the car to go from zero to
100 kilometres an hour
well mrs. Wilke afraid of penis likes
the minimalist interior design buttons
are few and far between and the entire
navigation and vehicle data runs through
the system here on the display you can
adjust the radio volume with this knob
but also via the touchscreen to the car
also scores points for it's simple
handling but what's the overall verdict
be dynamic inna says why said when
decided to call a car with protected air
bumps the cactus is anybody's guess but
inside and out features like the front
seat bench really makes it 2 n c4 cactus
a real standout in omelets bang on
damage assess the trends this year
cactus mulish my love us and love us
Opel has unveiled a crossover of the
atom called atom rocks the pint-sized
city car now sports SUV inspired plastic
body cladding a higher clearance and a
swing top canvas roof
the base model will start at about 16
thousand euros in Germany for a bit more
you can also get one of the two one
liter 3-cylinder engines their fuel
consumption starts at 4.5 liters per 100
kilometers